hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast inference of genes
signatures associated with response and
resistance to targeted amino therapies
presented by dr. Shirley Liu professor
of statistics biostatistics and
computational biology at Dana Farber
Cancer Institute in the harvard
university i'm susie valdez of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's events we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab routes is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window and type that
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice that you
will be viewing this presentation in a
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon located at the
lower right if you have any trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use that
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem can use this educational
presentation is offering continuing
educational credits please click on the
button at the bottom left hand corner
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me now in welcoming
dr. Shirley Liu I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr. Liu
Thank You Sussie for that introduction
it's my great pleasure to introduce our
work and we are a computational biology
group and so we develop statistical
models to understand cancer therapy you
know nowadays precision cancer medicine
is really on the rise people are very
excited to use genomic approaches to
better prescribe or diagnose or
prescribe drugs for cancer patients for
example at dana-farber when patients
coming in once they are diagnosed their
tumors get a mutation profile with the
hope that with the specific mutations
identified on the tumors we could find a
better drug to the patient and indeed a
lot of the patients either will get
specific targeted therapy or they will
be put on a trial that oncologists are
testing new therapies unfortunately even
with the tremendous cost that you know
is associated with drug discovery for
example on average it takes 12 years and
300 million dollars to develop a drug
and 2% of those development efforts well
finally and in fda approved the drugs um
for a lot of cancer therapies only
limited response rates have been
observed and also patient only observe
very limited survival benefits for
example many targeted therapies you
observe just a survival benefit of six
months or 12 months and eventually
patient develop therapy resistance and
some patients will not even respond to
the therapy initially and so um we are
hoping that you know with the high
throughput data available in the cancer
community we can develop computational
methods that can help us predict which
patients who are respond to a therapy
and which patients will not and also
whether eventually they will develop a
resistance to the therapy the ideal data
for this our mutation or expression
profiles of patients directly from those
clinical trials for example if
or the patient is treated with the
therapy we'll take the tumor we do some
light color profiling after the patient
is treated with the therapy if the tumor
is there whether it's drinking or
continuing to grow if we can get a
biopsy sample of those tumors and
especially later on if the patient
develop resistance to the same drug we
can get either surgical biopsy samples
from the patient and do molecular
profiling of those and then comparing
the pretreatment post-treatment where
patient is sensitive and they'll also
close treatment when patient become
resistance and look at their differences
that would be really the ideal data
unfortunately these kind of data are
very very difficult your patient do now
want to get surgical or examples or
ideally not even biopsy samples after
their disease have progressed and the
tumor metastasis are resistant to the
drug and so we are wondering what other
model systems are possible if we don't
have patient data directly for example
we can derive cell lines that are from
the patient tumors initially so we can
grow these cells in the petri dish and
then we can treat the cell we know for
example the cancer cells have certain
mutations we can treat this out with a
drug and initially maybe the patient
where the cell lines are sensitive to
the drug but after a period say a few
weeks or a few months the cell will
become resistant to the drug and so we
could do gene expression profiling of
those cell lines that initially respond
but later becoming resistant and see
what are the differences between the two
and these are helpful data although it's
still very very limited you know what is
available in the public domain and so um
what is end up being very helpful is
these kind of compound screen data that
is in terms of the number increasing
very very quickly so um there are 3
published studies now where the data is
available and such effort are increasing
for example in the CT RPE project
scientists look at they collected 8
twenty-four different cancer cell wives
and treated treated the cell lines was
500 different compounds for the the GSC
project is also connect close to a
thousand cell lines treated it was 250
compounds in the ccoet project it was
like close to 500 cell lines treated
with 24 compounds and so these kind of
data are still growing each cancer cell
line has been carefully molecular
profile so we know their mutation status
we know their gene expression status and
then when the cell lines are treated
with each compound we can measure how
when the compound are at different
concentration or doses we can measure
how much the cells are being killed by
the compound which is the sensitivity of
the cell to a particular compound so
this is these data are really growing we
actually have a much better basis to
start looking at cancer drug response
and one type of data that's actually
coming out
more recently although right now it's
still limited it's very very promising
is functional genomics screens so these
include
shrna or si RNA screens or CRISPR
screens or or screens so the idea is
here we can grow also the cell in a huge
population of say 100 million cells and
then using a lentivirus 2 or ovary
expression vector to introduce things
like you know go to the different cells
either over express meltdown or knock
out a particular gene and then treat the
cell with a particular drug and compare
with the cells not treated with a drug
we can ask when a particular cell is
ovary expressing a gene or knock out a
particular gene would that change the
cell sensitivity to the drug that's
that's treating the cells and so this is
also very very promising although this
kind of data right now it's still on the
rise we're hoping that the more data
will become available and so um simple
for the motivation after the work on
targeted therapy we want to develop
computational and statistical methods
for
intubation to be able to predict
response to cancer therapy on model
cancer therapy resistance and also
understand a mechanism of resistance and
hopefully to identify combination
therapies in the long run to overcome
drug resistance so um as I mentioned
before for a particular computational
model we are looking at compound the
screens as I mentioned is hundreds of
cell line cancer cell lines treated with
like hundreds of different drugs and so
this is one example for example in here
every thought represent a particular
cell line and inhibition on the y-axis
really measures how much the cell is
sensitive to a particular drug and in
this case we are using a Arafa heater or
the data is actually be wrapping here
treating cells and so in general cancer
cell lines that Harbor a b-raf mutation
of the 600m mutation will overall be
more sensitive to the drug so as you can
see all the red dots which harvard
appear as mutation have less sensitivity
to the dragon then i sort of has more
sensitivity or or more cell growth
inhibition than those wall type cells um
however if we know kind of two genes
like in the left side you can see with
the EGFR gene now we discretize the data
into three groups based on the level of
EGFR gene expression and so you can see
even though the red dots in general are
these pre rup mutated cells are more
sensitive to the b raf inhibitor and
sensitivity actually is influenced by
the level of EGFR gene expression based
on this left figure you can see the
higher the EGFR gene expression the less
sensitive is the cell to the baraka
heater on the right side is the opposite
example where we are looking at the lef
left one gene and you can see here the
higher the expression of the left one
the more sensitive is the south
to the b raf inhibitor and so we wonder
whether we can find similar effect in
the genome by checking every gene in
using these compound screens and so we
develop this computational model we call
it computational analysis of resistance
or care this is a regression based
method so in this case why is the drug
response or inhibition you know whether
the cell is sensitive to the drug so a
high number would mean the cell is very
sensitive to the drug and cancer cells
are dying after the drug treatment
whereas a low number would mean that
that's how is not so sensitive to a drug
and then in this particular case we need
to only look at the drugs where the
target gene is known where we're you
know mostly looking at targeted therapy
and so that the status of the target
gene is is this X in the regression
model here so X most of the time is a
mutation status for example using EGFR
inhibitor to target cancer cells with
EGFR mutation b raf inhibitor target to
target
b raf mutated cells we could also use
expression as kind of a quantitative
model in here and so among all the
cancer compound screens we need to
select those specific screens where we
do see you know like as the previous
slide show in this case the b-raf
mutation needs to at least a separate
patient response disorder so my response
to the particular drug and if we don't
even see this we can't use this model
and so on those cell lines where we on
the drugs where we do see the target the
drug target gene status is separating
the sensitive versus not so sensitive so
wise then we can look at the care model
and so here we are hoping to identify
another or at least evaluate every other
gene key
in this regression model so P is another
interacting gene by itself it has a
coefficient B in here which says you
know maybe another gene always have some
effect on the drug sensitivity but in
addition we care about this last term in
the regression model the cxp C is the
coefficient X is the mutated or the
targeted gene status and P is the
interacting gene and so the idea is you
know if we look at the second line let
me use the pointer here if we look at
this part you can see um what we care
about is on this regression we're asking
let's evaluate a particular gene this
gene might have its only effect like
this base effect but also maybe it is
also interacting with the target gene
here C which eventually well influence
the overall drug sensitivity of the cell
to the drug and so on this this figure
on the right you can see um we care
about the beat itself and also we care
about the C defect so usually if the C
is less than zero it means that when the
expression of the gene is high the
sensitivity of the cell to the drug will
decrease whereas if the C is larger than
zero it means that when it expressed
higher the cell will be even more
sensitive to the drug and so okay so
let's go back to the original example
there so remember there are two genes we
are showing before the GFR and left ones
and so in this case you can see that
yeah so for EGFR the care score so the
cares for is basically a normalized the
B plus C score on the coefficient in the
previous page and so here we look at the
care score you can see here and EGFR
gene is a negative value which means
when you Jeff our gene expression go up
the sensitivity to the cell
- this drug actually decrease whereas
the with left one it's a positive score
here which means that's when laughs one
gene expression go up the cell will be
even more sensitive to the drug and you
can see from the p-values these are very
very significant and so um you wonder
you know this is just to example we can
always pick and choose the fact is we
don't actually pick and choose we test
every gene in the genome as the key
where's the target the target gene acts
you know whether it's a B Rafi he'd be
Roth or EGFR inhibitor for EGFR mutation
status so once we know the drug we know
the target gene which has every gene in
the genome for this potential
interaction and so where's the drug
screen well get a care score which is a
genome-wide score every gene gets a care
score which is what we show on this
previous slide on the blue and red
square and so every gene has a score and
later on if somebody has a cell line or
a tumor based on the expression of
genome-wide gene expression we can
correlate this genome-wide signature
with the care score which is also a
genome-wide signature and if we see a
good correlation we can predict that
this patient actually will respond to
the drug
whereas if the tumor cell line doesn't
have good correlation we will predict
that it won't respond to us with for the
drug we're interested in so in this case
rather than cherry-picking specific
genes we evaluate the score for every
gene in the genome and use it to predict
drug sensitivity of that particular
tumor to the drug and so the effect of
each gene even if it's noisy from the
compound screens will not have overall
dramatic effect we take in fact you know
the overall
correlation of the samples and so as a
good standard to see how well this thing
works we look at cells where initially
there was a sensitive cell line and over
time when it's treated with the drug the
cell become resistant and we compared
the gene
expression differences between the
resistant line and the sensitive line
look at those differential genes and we
use those genes as as our gold standard
to see among the care scores that are
really high or low we can also rank the
genes by the care score and we see
whether we can recover those genes that
are differentially expressed between the
sensitive and resistant line and so you
know compare so we use this we evaluate
comparing with you know just the
correlation of the gene expression with
the drug effect or with ANOVA and you
can see overall actually the Karen model
works really well this is evaluated on
three targeted therapy for like Iraq
inhibitor her - inhibition and EGFR
inhibitors and so this is still testing
on resistant and sensitive cell lives we
want to see how well it actually worked
in patient tumors so so far when people
try to predict sensitivity to cell wise
in these compounds means that the
evaluation is usually just made on cell
lines we want to have a higher standard
to see whether our signature can predict
the tumor response so by looking at
published clinical trials for example in
this 12 there are 12 patients treated
with the b-raf so the patient tumors
have the b-raf mutation we know that
they already have the mutation then we
want to see whether the patient will
really respond to the RAF inhibitor
using the tumor gene expression you can
see using care on the left side we can
actually predict a pretty good response
and also predict how long the patient
will have a progression-free survival on
the right side we compare a number of
other approaches you know care has the
best performance and also compared to
Christmas means you know we actually do
a better performance compared to crisper
a crisper crisper knock out or screens
as shrna screens also chronically
treated
it's all eyes and so actually the cell
lies here in terms of patient survival
prediction it doesn't do as well the so
the first one was a giraffe inhibitor
the next one we look at another clinical
trial where patients were treated with a
Herceptin which is a la continent which
is her to inhibition for patient in her2
positive breast cancer and so here we
don't have to over a patient survival we
only know whether the patient responded
to the drug to have observable tumor
shrinkage and so based on this we look
at whether the care can actually predict
whether this patient can respond and you
can see we have a good saturation of
those responders versus non responders
and again our method outperform you know
the chronic treatment actually here
chronic treatment you get a pretty good
result SH as our si RNA and work screen
in the next in the next slide we look at
patients with the EGFR mutation treated
with EGFR inhibitor and again using the
care model we can make a pretty good
prediction and also do much better than
the other in experimental approaches and
so you wonder you know maybe these
clinical trials have too few patient
which is true I think in most of the
published clinical trials from academic
settings where expression data is
available and so we without has a
chemotherapy so chemotherapy although is
not really like a targeted therapy some
of the chemo therapies that are tested
on a current compound screens do have a
known target gene for example paclitaxel
is a very widely used chemotherapy and
existing studies have reported that the
tubulin gene is really the main target
and and we did look at a tool in gene
expression I indeed the patient was
hired tubulin are more sensitive to
tackle paxil which towers that we could
use the care model on the existing
chemotherapy trials of paclitaxel um and
so here we collected
three different clinical trials remember
so here the care model was trained on
cell lines treated with chemotherapy and
then based on the signature we tested
three clinical trials of patient and
tumors have also gone through gene
expression profiling and based on the
expression and our care prediction from
the cell lines we predict whether the
patient will respond or not respond to
the chemotherapy and you can see indeed
we can have a good prediction on the
left side that you know the responders
versus malice founders show a good
separation and and also the method seem
to work very much better than
experimental approaches so in here the
clinical data is is patient that are
treated in one of these clinical
settings based on an expert signature we
will want to see why they can predict in
the other and so here you can see based
on a you see if that's better but based
on accuracy it doesn't actually
outperform and so overall it seems like
with the care model even though it's
derived from the cell lines we have good
performance even on the patient's tumor
trials and so questions these things
will be all known targets you know is
well-established wells can we predict
something new and so we we tried that
and so here we look at the patent it for
a her2 positive breast cancer so it
turns out that this particular compound
has been tested in all three CCR ec TI p
and c GP three different compound cohort
and they have actually very consistent
result i'm showing two genes PR k d3 and
a KT - I mean as having very negative
care scores meaning that if we can
inhibit PR k d3 and 883 the cancer cells
will be even more sensitive to Latinate
and we also look at a Jinni expression
so these were chronically derived the
cell lines where we should like the cell
line which we did for a long term and
then look at the resistance cell lines
differentially expression and
can see also here these two genes have a
much higher gene expression compared to
them to the sensitive cell line and then
the last column we are looking at a
clinical actual clinical cohort which is
we look at the association of this gene
expression with the pathological
completely starts in lopatina
treatment cohort and you can see they
are negatively correlated which you know
also indicate that if the expression of
these two genes are high the patient
will not respond so well to continue
treatment um and so we ask us so
actually there are more games available
on this list we look at these two
because they have inhibitors available
indeed for a KT 3 and it has already
been reported in another study and so we
now test PR KD 3 which has an inhibitor
but no clinical testing yet and so when
we first want to do a genetic test to
make sure that you know we can if we
knock down PR KD 3 using RNA I indeed on
the left side we can see we can knock
down the PR KD 3 and also understand as
KBR 3 so wise with Herceptin or the her2
amplification the cells indeed will be
more sensitive to latinum so genetically
we can validate this now it has the
inhibitors and so there are two
inhibitors we found that inhibit PR KD 3
we want to see whether this drug
actually works synergistically
synergistically with lumpectomy because
sometimes when you have on the cell you
treated with a drug it would be a little
secret we know is another drug it would
be a little secret but you add them
together is that we'll be a lot sicker
and so want to make sure that um the
synergy is is you know the code
treatment inhibition subtracted by the
additive effect of the inhibition we can
actually can see more than what we
expect just by adding the two drives if
they don't synergize and so so on the on
the figure here on the right side
you can see if it's red it means that
this energy score is positive meaning
that indeed lapatinib and the pr kitty
inhibitors show synergy and so we try a
different pattern if those and also try
a different PR kb3 those and you can see
in general we see a good synergy and on
the left side you can also see the
inhibition of the cell growth and after
we do the coal treatment and we later on
also derived a resistance Ally in the
lab ourself so initially the cell line
as KP our three cell lines are sensitive
to the Palatinate drug but after
prolonged drug treatment the cells
become resistant and so with this
resistant line initially we did see that
it's not sensitive to the drug but then
if we treat now together as kb3
inhibitor as well as our PR kd3
inhibitor as well as the lapatinib onto
this resistance cell you can see that
cell become much much more sensitive to
the drug drug combination and also
showing a good synergy um so in terms of
her to inhibition in addition to
lapatinib which is a small molecule
inhibitor there is also trastuzumab
which is an antibody drug targeting her
too and so in addition to test a
combination of PR KD 3 he beat her with
the patent it we also tested this
combination with the antibody
trastuzumab and you can also see good
sensitive good synergy of the drug the
two different drugs to the consumer so
in summary we found you know cell line
compound screens that are done on a big
cancer cell and concord can contain very
informative biomarkers that can predict
clinical tumor response to either
targeted or chemotherapy and so we
developed this care model with
she uses an interaction regression to
identify the facts of another gene
interacting with the specific drug
target to influence drug response and
use it to predict a clinical tumor
response from this analysis we also
identified PR kd3 inhibition as a way to
synergize with her to inhibition either
Balikatan it or has no map in the her2
positive breast cancers so this is the
first part of my talk which is about
targeted therapy the next part I want to
talk about you know immunotherapy as we
know recent years I will see a lot of
progress in immune checkpoint blocker
development so um so in general the idea
is you know patient tumors usually are
recognized by the immune cells or T
cells for example and but then the tumor
cells
well-well-well Express this pv-1 were
city CTL now e to the tumor well Express
PDL 1 or p7 these are ligands which
actually interact with the PB 1 and
ctla4 receptors on the other immune
cells like t-cells
and so the T cells even though it's
recognizing the tumor as foreign and
trying to kill it the the the PB 1 and
CDI wait for once it's interacting with
the ligand then that he saw become
dysfunctional and so the development of
the immune checkpoint blocker is we
developed companies develop antibodies
to block this ligand receptor
interaction which allowed the T cells to
get activated to recognize the tumor
cells as foreign and attack it and so um
the good news is that the patient who
respond to these tumors you you know
first of all these tumors have a lot of
mutation these are the hardest to treat
tumors but those patient who benefits
usually we can see prolonged survival so
patient can really be cured five year
ten year
is free the bad news is that only a
minority of those patients respond and
so and this is a very expensive drug and
there are some known side effects like
autoimmune side effects and so the
question is really can we predict before
the patients were treated it was a drug
whether they will respond whether they
were benefit from immune checkpoint
blocker and so far many things have been
reported for example whether the t-cells
are you to treating the tumor the second
is whether the tumor has a lot of
mutations to really allow the t-cell to
recognize it as foreign the level of PDL
1 which is the level of this ligand on
the tumor cells and are also recently
there are some reports that that he cell
receptor repertoire diversity might also
be influenced arrival and so each of
these studies are done on a small you
know pretty small cohort and of course
the the billion dollar question is
really how do we really predict it even
with existing biomarkers there are still
clinical trials that failed because
there's no good biomarker to predict
which patient will respond and so it may
not really show you enough benefits in
the clinical trials and so we want to
build a biomarker for immunotherapy
response the relevant data is large
clinical studies with immunotherapy
treatment unfortunately so far the
published cohorts have very limited
number of patients and also limited
number of cancer types so so far you
know you know check that checkpoint
blockers have only be using very few
cancer types um what we do have that you
know the data abundance is large
clinical studies without you know Sarah
P we have these large cohorts for
example in the u.s. there is the TCGA
profile where we have profiles / tinta
or scientists have profiled over 10,000
tumors over 33 different cancer types
ICGC is an international effort from
europe asia including the US and target
is kind of a pediatric tumor
switching for the US um but the thing is
none of these patients when their tumors
are profile these are surgically remove
tumors these are mostly primary tours
that our treatment not use and so the
patient hasn't been treated with
anything yet
question is can we actually see
something from those tumors to tell us
what happens to the immune system so our
hypothesis is that the tumor immunes so
the even the treatment naive samples
maybe there are already some interesting
information about the patient immune
system or the tumor immune micro
environment which can tell us about
immunotherapy response and so so far
with immune checkpoint blockers there
are two hypotheses where it will not
work the first type is on the right side
these tumors if you look at them under
the slides tissue staining the tumor
staining you can see that the t-cells
are not getting into the tumor and so
it's not infiltrating the tumor to
recognize the tumor as kind of foreign
antigens and so these are called immune
cold tumors on the left side so you know
if the TESOL can't get in then it can't
kill the tumor cells and the left side
is inside the tumor you can see the T
cells into treating the tumor but it's
exhausted you know maybe it's trying too
hard and eventually it's just too tired
and so these are called a T so this
function where t-cell exhaustion and so
these are hot tumors or inflamed tumors
but the T cell is there but it's not
doing its job and so we want to see you
know maybe the you nanosec you fail to
work because either you can't get in the
tumor or it gets in the tumor but it's
not doing its job because it's too
exhausted or dysfunctional and so let's
first model things on the left side for
the dysfunction and so for here we again
now know cattle existing TCGA data or
the large tumor cohort data where you
know hundreds of patient
profiles for these cancer types and for
example we see in the TCGA for melanoma
and the triple negative breast cancer we
look at the patient's survival that the
y-axis is the survival and so this is
survival curve we can see the the t-cell
does cytolytic activity of the t-cells
so basically when the t-cell level is
high and also the T cells are activated
overall the patient have better survival
so these are the red lines meaning that
when their T cells are high and it's
actually doing its job it's activated we
do see a survival benefit however this
is there is a condition for example we
look at the Sybil beating a CBL beating
this is a well-known she sought this
functional gene and so you can see this
is a gang in melanoma samples and when
the SIBO beat gene expression level is
very high cd8 t-cell doesn't even have
any survival benefits on the right side
you can see only when the see Bobe gene
expression is low we can see the
survival benefits when I see b8 he saw
or cytolytic activity is high the
patient do have better survival so by
the way here I'm the sign oolitic
activity we use the gene expression
level of cd8 a cd8 B groans I'm a
grandson B and porphyrin level um so you
can see this actually is similar to the
previous caramel that we derived this
new model here it's also regression and
the response here on the Y here the H is
the kind of the survival the hazard of
the survival curve and that p here is
really the level of the lytic Tisa
activity which is measured by these five
genes expression level and then we ask
whether there's another gene life c will
be which interact with the level of T
cells or analytic activity T cells to
influence the overall patient survival
so we want to see on this survival curve
whether the expression of another gene
might be interacting with t-cells three
in flown over a patient's arrival so you
can see this is quite similar to the
previous care model and so it has again
we don't just carry Pete gene so it has
many many genes you can see every gene
we can look at there in fact so for
example on this table on the right you
can see on PDL one which is a well-known
he's like that but this is the ligand
the tumor expressed in order to suppress
their order repress the t-cell function
it has a positive score meaning that
when pder Y is very high actually the
level of T Solomon is high it doesn't
really do much whereas the bottom gene
which is in blue here this is actually
melanoma antigen gene which is
specifically recognized by T cells when
it's highly expressed that he saw is
really there to recognize this tumor as
a alien and trying to kill the tumor
cell so it has a very negative value
here and so you can see um the value
really tell us whether she saw well work
well or not work well and so um we we
also test every gene the gene allow and
give them a score even though some are
significant some are not significant way
still estimated z-score when it's not
significant it could be pretty close to
zero and so um when a particular patient
has a tumor a gene expression we
correlate their expression with this
overall signal and here if it's
correlated it actually tell us the T
cells are dysfunctional because you can
see here PVL Y is a positive score in
here when it's very high that these
dolls are there but it's not doing its
job it's similar to the Siebel B gene
and so if the tumor expression correlate
with this genome-wide score it tells us
the T cells are exhausted and it's now
working so immunotherapy may not work
whereas on the right side when the gene
expression correlation is low we say
okay well maybe the T cell is there and
it's not exhausted you will probably
will benefit from the immunotherapy and
so and we do this for many different
cohorts that we collected and so far
what we have seen is that the signature
this is a genome-wide signature the
genome-wide signatures that we derive
the from and the neutral cancer is
triple negative breast cancer
neuroblastoma AML and melanoma are
actually quite correlated also um if we
look at those genes that have the very
significant this dysfunctional score
they sound the signal that baby's
positive genes you can see on the right
side this is a particular this is a
study from MD Anderson recently
published nature paper where are the
mouse are treated long term to see that
he saw dysfunction this is long term
treated CMV so that he saw become
gradually dysfunctional five days 14
days 28 days 60 days after the the AL
CMV treatment and the t-cells are
becoming increasingly dysfunction or
exhausted and you can see our tied score
inserts are there are signatures for
indeed over time you can see with time
these signatures become strong stronger
in the mouse models and so um we also
see some other studies for example this
is mouse studies for t-cell exhaustion t
reg gene activation a screen where she
cells were like using shrnas be looking
at whether T cells with really
proliferate and get activated in a mouse
and also mouse treated we see how for
looking at those differential genes you
can see in those studies they each have
hits versus non hits and we ask can our
signature derived from TCGA or these
five cohorts really predict those hits
versus non hiss and you can see the blue
dot and red does indeed we can separate
you know we our score also scored them
for those hit jeans and on the right
side this is also looking at whether we
can capture those hits in the screen in
those different Mouse studies and you
can see the signature that we derived
from each of these cancer types they
already work pretty well but if we take
their average which means that we get
the most robust signature in general we
do have better performance and so this
is kind of modeling on the left side
before we look at know that he saw is
there but it's not doing its job it's
exhausted and dysfunctional on the right
side where are we now want to model he's
out exclusion in the code tumors and so
these are the cases where the Tisa
cannot in to treat the tumor and we read
some papers especially Thomas K asked
his review where he explained you know
when the t-cell cannot get in what are
the possibilities one is the mtsc
myeloid arrives as your cells one middle
one is cancer associated fiberglass and
then also tumor associated micro phage
so when in the tumor microenvironment
you have high level of these three then
the t-cells cannot in to treat the tumor
so I'm from the public data we also
extracted that gene expression
signatures or the gene expression
genome-wide gene expression level of MDS
C calf and ham and then look at for
example in this case is melanoma samples
and whether the level of cd8 t-cell
infiltration is correlated with the MDS
decaf or ham levels and you can see in
general and so each dot here is one
example in the TCGA a melanoma tumor in
general if the tumor has a high level of
MDS C or high correlation with the MDS C
signature you will have low cd8
infiltration
also when the tumor has high fibroblast
high macrophage you will have low cd8
t-cell infiltration and then on the very
right side is the mean we have reached a
signature from all three together and
and then you can see in general when the
tumor has high
correlation with this signature indeed
it will have lower cdat into Trisha and
the correlation is even more robust here
um and so um we use this to really model
kind of the Hisao exclusion when the
seesaw cannot get into the tumor and so
I'm now let's look at what's the
relationship with between these are
dysfunction and he's our exclusion on
the left side this is all this melanoma
samples within TCGA and each dot is a is
a particular tumor and the color tells
us how much the t-cell cytolytic T cells
are activated um so you can see this
negative correlation which means that
you know some tumors have she's a
exclusion where the T cells cannot get
in that's on the lower right side but
whereas other tumors the T cells can get
in and it's pretty the cytolytic
activity is high but then also you start
to see T Saudis function when the T
cells become too tired and on the right
side we're looking at all the TCGA
cancer types so every cancer type is a
different cancer and so on the right
side this one is lung cancer there's a
squamous lung cancer so in general lung
cancer is pretty cold
tumor you can see here you know in
general the to the tumor has low T cell
infiltration and on the upper left
corner this is a kidney cancer kidney
cancer actually is a surprising cancer
type that respond well to immunotherapy
partly because it's T cell infiltration
is very high it's a hard to work and so
um so at the end we put the two models
together we call it a tide it's kind of
like a tide detergent which here stands
for tumor immune dysfunction and
exclusion so we model two things
this function is modeling when the T
cells is in the tumor but it's too
exhausted to kill the cancers and but
then exclusion is the other situation
where the tumor is code and the T cell
cannot get into the tumor so how
we do this when some money profile a
tumor based on a gene expression we
first decide whether it's cd8 high or C
at Lourdes cytolytic activities high or
low
if it's high we say okay the kiss out is
infiltration infiltrating then we use
the previous this functional score
genome-wide score to correlate with the
tumor gene expression if it is
correlated we'll say okay the tour he
saw is there but it's too exhausted so
probably it will not respond but if the
T saw is there but not this function
already exhausted maybe the patient will
benefit on the left side when the cd8 he
saw is low we then ask do we see the
exclusion signatures based on the
macrophage fibroblasts and MDS d
signatures and so if the correlation is
high it means that the you know
macrophage or MDS year or fiberglass is
actively excluding the T cells from
getting into the tumor so patient
probably wouldn't respond but if it
doesn't have the good the signature will
say well maybe this I haven't got a
chance to go in yet so maybe they will
still respond and so that's how we model
them together and so let's see how it
works we look at the two different
published clinical studies the first is
the anti PD one at well this is from
Roger law and Tony rivers lab at UCLA
and so you can see we first are created
by the cd8 infiltration level when the
CDA the level or the cytolytic activity
level is high we look at the t cell
dysfunction and you can see as the
dysfunction increased the patient are
less likely to respond to Union or
therapy so here red is responding and
blue is not responding
whereas on the left side when the tumors
are cold you then we look at how much
the T cells are not getting into the
tumor because of some active repression
by fiberglass or macrophage and so you
can see here when the new imputation is
low and the exclusion signature is very
very strong then a patient usually don't
respond to email or therapy
whereas when the exclusion signature is
not so strong the patient's do have
pretty good chance of responding and the
bottom is another file this is anti CPOE
for treatment that's done in Ally violin
and the levi garraway slab again we see
similar trend when the t-cell level is
high we look at this function and the
stronger the dysfunction the less likely
the patient will respond when the T cell
infiltration is low or the central
Ithaca activity is low we look at the T
cell exclusion and the stronger the
exclusion the worse the patient survival
and we cannot predict this at a hundred
percent accuracy in fact nobody can
predict it at 100 percent accuracy but
you know we see some promising results
so overall you can see for the
responders and non-responders for those
two trials indeed we can actually see a
good separation in terms of the overall
predictive power and so far what has
been used is mutations the overall tumor
mutation load and the pv Elwin levels
that you know people have used it in the
clinical settings and you can see the
tide model can outperform both we also
look at other potential markers that
people have discussed including
interferon gamma levels you know this is
IPS is a computational method and
somatic copy number changes so in these
other method in general we see you know
each is promising to a certain degree
but you know actually this tide model
perform the best and not only we can
predict a response we can see the
overall patient survivor of the patient
over time for anti pd-1 and anti CPOE
for that you know the patient that I
have so eat either their t-cells are too
exhausted or eat or or if their t-cells
can get in because of those suppressive
factors those patient in general don't
do very well in their overall survival
where is the remaining ones that are
more likely to respond to immunotherapy
also they are more likely to survive
much longer and so in summary we found
that the gene expression of treatment
naive
tumors from the pcj already contain
information on the patient immune
potential in the micro tumor
microenvironment and this does the
signatures that we derived from the TCGA
without the immunotherapy can be used to
predict the patient responds to
immunotherapy and so in addition to
actually just arriving a biomarker from
here we also care about some of the
really strong genes I'm like pd-1 or
sorry like a PDL one some of these genes
that can be actually targeted to improve
the immunotherapy response so within our
lab and our collaborator were kind of
validate some of those genes who's in
vision can actually improve the
immunotherapy response so I want to
thank members of my lab who participated
in the study and the study is led by a
very talented postdoc Tom's young so
both the care model and pied model was
developed by pong and he also did the
experimental validation for the care
model for the pilot validation currently
stand with collaborating with Kaimuki
fennec to do the experimental validation
I also want to thank my other colleagues
John Astor is on a care model
Attilio is a computation computational
collaborator
statistics collaborator miles brownies
our cancer biologist collaborator Gordon
Freeman is the PB 1 PB halwa expert it
also gave us a lot of help in vivo
validation so I also want to thank the
funding agency for their support so yeah
so in general you know my in my lab in
addition to this computational modeling
we also study used using IP genetic
profiles and also CRISPR screens to look
at cancer in a more holistic approach
because you know we believe that CRISPR
squeezed and also mutation analysis can
give us information about targeted
therapy and these targeted therapy
usually just directly try to kill the
cancer cells um you know um you know
therapy is more trying to boost the
patient immune system and not directly
target the cancer cells but use the
immune system to kill the cancer cells
and whereas with epigenetic therapy
which is also some area we are working
on we feel like it's kind of just tuning
the system balance and so in the long
run we believe only a good combination
of the three these are very
complementary approaches good
combination of the three well hopefully
help us to reach this cancer moonshot
goal maybe we don't cure cancer 2020 but
you know in fairly you know foreseeable
future we can see most cancer getting
cured so thank you very much for your
attention so that comes close my talk
any questions thank you so much dr. Lu
for that informative presentation and we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that green Q&A button at the
bottom left of the presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the sign
button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's take a look at what
our audience members are asking today we
have a great audience today our first
question is in the tide model you first
need to decide whether the tumor is cold
or hot so how do you determine the
cutoff for this dr. Lu a really good
question here yeah really good question
here how do we decide to close our heart
first of all I mentioned we use five
gene markers cd8 a be random a B and
porphyrin so for TCGA we can look at all
10,000 tumors together and usually you
see a majority of the tumors are
early cold but then a subset of the
tumors will have a high level and so
there we can use some standard cutoff
however depending on the specific cohort
for example in general as we mentioned
kidney cancers almost all the tumors are
hot so there we only look at this
function whereas you know maybe for some
other tumors like prostate most of the
tumors are cold and so there it's true
we need a standard whereas for example
other cancer types like melanoma samples
you would see actually some patients are
hot some patients are cold so in this
two clinical trials we mentioned we just
take the tumor we calculate the average
level of those five genes and so then if
the tumor expression of those five genes
are above the average and then we say
it's hot whereas if it's lower we call
it we call it a code tumor but indeed I
think so for melanoma this might be an
easier question but for some other
tumors exactly where the cut line could
still be pretty tricky
Thank You dr. Luo we have time for one
more question and we have a wonderful
question from one of our audience
members in your care model you use
differentially expressed genes between
sensitive resistant cells as the gold
standards is this a good choice and also
you mentioned that the care performs
better than the CRISPR screens which
some people might consider as a better
gold standard can you explain this a
little more thank you yeah another very
very good question here yeah about the
gold standard you know we do get asked
by reviewers you know why do you use a
cell light sensitive resistant line look
at the differential genes unfortunately
right now in the cancer field nobody
have real gold standard and so we would
say using cell lines chronically treated
with the drug to derive a sense it's a
resistant line and looking at
differential gene expression it's kind
of a proxy of a gold standard I wouldn't
say it's perfect it may be like a silver
standard I would say it's it's it's not
the best but we don't really have better
standard um some might argue that you
know crisper screen should really be
much more important you know you treated
the cell so first of all you use CRISPR
to knock out different genes and you
treat us always the drug compared with
so without the drug and you look at the
sensitivity of the cell to the drug when
different genes are knocked out or not
done somehow in our analysis we found it
to work you know the the care model to
work even better than CRISPR which is a
little surprising because right now our
tide model was generated on compound
screens over hundreds of cell lines no
for the same drug we look at a hundred
cells have a cell perform based on the
expression of those order mutation
status of the cell whereas CRISPR screen
right now it's two very limited I know
people are generating a lot of CRISPR
experience right now the initial
most of the public screen so far were
just on baseline cell lines not treated
with any drug and so we are only looking
at a very limited compound sorry the
crisper screens and the single cell lie
and look at the crisper result we
believe if you have hundreds of cell
lines treated with the drug and then
follow like a crisper screen with that
drug we should be able to derive a good
model much better I would say potential
biomarker for the therapy response and
so crisper only doesn't work that well
when you profile on a single cell line
was more cell lines it should work
better doctor you don't want to thank
you again for your wonderful
presentation and truly your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcasts possible before we go I want to
remind the audience members that today's
webcast will be available for demand
on-demand viewing through January 2017
you'll receive an email from labyrinth
is webcast will be available for replay
please share this announcement with your
colleagues you may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thanks
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye